I actually think that's perception more
than reality people that are over 40 did
not grow up in a manner where they
thought to be a Creator because it
didn't exist we probably have more
conversations with Brands trying to
reach to creators that are not under 35
year old demo we see unlimited
opportunities we see it all day long it
just feels like that's where the media
attention is which is true and
justifiable but I don't think that's
stopping your opportunity in any shape
or form really I don't we see that
pretty clear globally I think I wouldn't
worry about that because it's not true
brands are more and more trying to reach
all ages all sizes all shapes all demos